bien sûr que j'ai toujours marqué quand
j'écoute la musique c'est qu'au début on
est normal et tous que la musique est
calme et déclame musique commence à
beussent manège dans notre tête on sent
un peu beauf quoi on croit en plus je
suis pas loin tout le monde et je
voulais aujourd'hui témoigner de sa en
images
on se retrouve aujourd'hui sur call of
duty black ops sur xbox alors j'ai eu la
ps3 wii vous avez pu voir sur twitter et
sur ma chaîne secondaire mais un drop
shot comme une [ __ ] on l'a eu mais
j'ai pas encore pu avoir black up 2 sur
ps3 j'ai que bat
playstation battle all stars eux j'ai
quoi d'autre j'ai skylander et j'ai le
dernier god of war d'ailleurs je vous
ferai une petite vidéo sur le multi avec
fut parce qu'honnêtement il vaut le
détour alors écouter aujourd'hui je fais
cette petite vidéo sur call of wayne
j'ai pas l'habitude de faire des cadeaux
sur call of c'est vrai que j'avais
arrêté pendant longtemps mais bon qui
dit vidéo sur call of deep end crosetti
du punk rose 10 vidéos sur call of
facile vers des débiles non sans rire
les gens je vais juste vous présenter la
classe e et faire vous parler d'une
chose
ohwawa où on a eu à oui on a une coupe
bien chercheuse
il a un peu mince il attendait non cacao
à la technique chacun n'a pas marché
merde donc oui écoutez je vais présenter
la classe e s qui va s'afficher à droite
dès maintenant alors bon moi mon coup de
coeur ça a été le pacificateur alors je
sais pas trop si c'est une arme chute et
patxi teoco aprédia je m'intéresse plus
trop j'ai je m'en fout en fait je joue
juste bons à prévoir la 6e rennais lance
grenade c'est vrai que je ne jouerai pas
vraiment lance grenade dans le sens où
je trouve ça quand même
wen la fac je trouve ça quand même un
petit peu antijeu tout ce qui est à lens
grenade bbb betty etc mais bon on a fait
du tour je pense des trucs tchité nos
colonnes ce n'est plus d'actualité
et donc ouais alors pour moi le
pacifique [ __ ] je suis pas en tactique
le pacificateur ses voeux au delà ça bug
oh la vache c'est quoi cette qu ils sont
sérieux l'as monaco pour y retrouver sur
une partie des habitants au japon je
sais pas son héros shima là ils sont
encore 1960 à ceux qui jouent donc ouais
sympa vous n'êtes pas bon une arme
plutôt polyvalent dans le sens où elle
fait mal de loin comme de près elle a
une assez bonne cadence de tir elle
admire sans viseur laser qui n'est pas
dégueulasse voyage à rabat s'est ajusté
de loin un bon mois nous monsieur
chinoise mais en temps normal il est
possible d'ajuster correctement avec
cette arme alors on met un petit
silencieux pour être inscrits sur des
maps comme ça mais bon après je vous
cache pas que sur des matches comme je
sais plus les maps serré dans celui-ci
common quelles sont leurs noms je ne
sais plus bon niveau c'est pas trop
améliorer c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
qu'on va on va ranger non alors on
regarde avec la sauce on sera peut-être
en fin de partie à une chose appelée des
snipers d'ailleurs le sniper mode que je
ne suis plus trop enfin surtout dans ce
colloque je sais pas si c'est valable
pour vous mais moi oui on s'est bouffé
un train où ça ça me le dire femmes
d'ailleurs
non non non ont pu sérieusement moi je
sais pas si c'est valable aussi pour
vous mais moi dans ce call of duty et
dans black ops un aussi
bon j'arrive pas à jouer sniper c'est à
dire que autant dans les dents les
modern warfare je me démerde eh bien ça
allait c'était pas trop une catastrophe
ou quoi mais alors dans ces call of là
c'est abominable je sais pas ce que j'ai
du mal bon vous l'avez bien vu dans la
vidéo l'homme le plus le monde d'oz die
peur d'ailleurs on va prendre l'autre
classe leiber vous m'avez conseille de
jouer au ballon juste à ce que j'ai fait
et j'ai arriver mieux mais il a écouté
la collection et deux bars ça peut être
jouable au snipe joue évidemment ce fut
même si on veut réussir à ajuster les
nuits on se tapera des jolie et
sympathique et marqueurs comme on les
adore alors oui je joue avec une
insertion tactique c'est d'habitude j'ai
joué à domicile n'y a pas vraiment de
deux buts a joué à l'insertion lorsqu'on
est évidemment en matière mort par
équipe mais en domination ça c'est
avantage lorsqu'on veut vraiment pour
jour un peu en team surtout qu'on veut
protéger ses sons un objectif précis
c'est toujours très utile de mettre une
petite insert à côté de celui ci
pourquoi vous connais pas vraiment de
round up vous essayez de le tenir alors
on va essayer cette arme
what
blague cette arme a disparu cette date
seuls
mondiale c'est de pire en pire c'est
georges et les hommes disparaissent
maintenant n'importe quoi qu'est ce que
c'est que ce délire bombay c'est d'aller
au balcon 3,60 et schott web
de malfi triple-triple qu'est-ce que tu
puisses tu as jusqu'au
bout c'est incroyable il est des fois ça
c'est ce qu'ils meurent a toujours un
grand colloque c'est la chance et la
malchance des fois tu tués oh non
l'homme qui met dix mille ont ajusté
c'est cool des fois tu peux mais faire
des parties abominable et puis la partie
d'après je sais pas la chance est avec
toi et tu assures en tout cas tu t'en
sors mieux beaucoup beaucoup mieux tu as
des petits coups du genre des doubles et
des tripes qui rentre
non le molenberg passe pas au ou le
coquin tu as il ya quand même un sacré
temps de
ça va mais on s'en sort pas trop mal on
a eu peur j'ai progressé grâce à vous
vous avez vu je me suis entraîné en
match en match on m'a dit de m'entraîner
contre des bots ce que j'ai fait c'était
plutôt bonne idée et toi
tu t'entends pas comme ça
dans le sens où l on m'a dit
alors
what the fuck ça c'est la connexion m'a
dit de m'entraîner comme des bottes
excusez moi c'est un peu chiant je me
coupe souvent mais je suis tout ému par
ce qui m'arrive dans le jeu cet homme là
bas est un ami harel qui habitent non
pas cet homme là bas que je vais en tuer
mais celui qu'a carambar et un homme qui
habite de qui habite pas dans ma classe
non mais qui dans la classe et qui
jouent avec moi avec son ami en écran
scindé alors j'espère qu'ils s'en sort
plutôt bien en tout cas nous ça a l'air
d'aller un hewitt écoutez si vous voulez
des conseils ou sniper je pense que on
va en faire un petit deuxième un
rassurez vous je pense qu'il faut jouer
contre les bots en match privé donc on
commence à mettre en face il même on
joue toujours en phase iib l'important
c'est de s'habituer à ajuster même pas
de l'aimer temps difficiles puisque de
manière les beaux temps difficiles dans
les colloques sont un petit peu de shit
et on va dire ce qui est juste vous
jouez en facile et vous apprenez ajusté
à gérer tout ça et honnêtement ça
entraîne la preuve s'agirait pas trop
mal là mais c'est vrai que le balisage
arrive pas il m'a un peu trop torres
copé femmes ont toujours là grenadiers
dans les vidéos pour ceux qui regardent
tomb raider vous devez avoir l'habitude
c'est vraiment très très mauvais rennes
alors au niveau des autres armes à quoi
j'ai touché dans ce call of on va
rejoindre un petit peu avec avec la
classe e on va dire que c'est l'éclaté
heureuse puisque c'est toujours les deux
classes que je joue en mode gros porc
alors celle-ci vous êtes un peu plus un
peu plus discret vous avez une petite
hache pour faire sauter assez bourrin et
à d'ailleurs regardez j'ai un t-shirt
hausse + family j'ai passé vous voyez
avec le familier là envers assez fun on
a fait une chute avec mon frère c'était
assez rigolo et on a fait celui-là et un
mario gothique enfin bon parenthèse
fermée et est donc oui un peu discret
cette classe est celle ci c'est je
trouve vraiment efficace on est discret
on a pas mal de ballons n'est pas trop à
court de balles on est toujours
en train de courir papapapa en cours
tranquille tranquille on s'arrête et on
a les atouts qui permettent de se couper
vite donc dès qu'on s'arrête tout ça
c'est assis bien comme classée comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure c'est assez
polyvalent enfin bref c'est avec lui que
j'ai trouvé
bon c'est efficace on va dire c'est
efficace sinon je vais vous parler un
petit peu de god of war que j'ai juste
ici alors écoutez au niveau du jeu ben
vous voyez les trois jeux que je venais
du tout à l'heure devant la foire aux
bestiaux nos stars et haskell d'ailleurs
alors skylanders c'est assez drôle je
connaissais pas le principe de jeu mais
en fait vous mettez tout simplement
défiguré sur un espèce de portail et le
perso apparaît dans le jeu alors quand
j'ai découvert ça c'était atroce oui je
vais d'aisance eux c'était avec ma
copine à tyson ross on a fait tout un
talus sight ou trop rigolo et doux et je
trouvais ça ouf et quand j'ai vu
l'éditeur et que j'ai vu que c'était
actifs dont je me suis dit [ __ ] ça
pouvait être que des radins com
activition qui devait faire sa junte est
sûre
alors les gars va faire un jeu on s'en
bat les côtes du jeu semaine des
figurines trop stylé et puis pour jouer
le personnage ils seront obligés
d'acheter à figurines à 15 euros
c'était vraiment pas bête comme idée
mais bon c'est sympathique bon après je
vous vois la bâche au la vache va se
faire défoncer l'âge de 100 ans c'est
quoi cette coop et 1 on est à une barre
quoi mec s'ils sont sérieux ou quoi sais
tu lances taste-vin qu'elle se lance
deux secondes après voilà ok elle
apparaît dans les airs car on accommode
alala ses soucis de connexion ce comme
assez énervant dans les colloques c'est
ce qui m'a poussé d'ailleurs à me
prendre une ps3 pour
pour justement jouer en solo a coûté au
pire on va on va passer en classe [ __ ]
en voilà obsédé revoir la personne
l'autre non halal va être dans mon dos
évidemment ce avec quoi est ce que j'ai
encore est l'esprit ultimate nice avec
la suite allez hop c'est parti on va se
faire une petite classe pupitre c'est
toujours sympa la classe pupitre quant à
une co pour y tu peux juste un fil très
discrètement moi je passe souvent par là
je me fais souvent des boîtes et par ici
d'ailleurs en passant attention
vous avez vu ça en me james bond mal ms
bombe
il croit qu'on est passé de copé au fond
c'est bon
il nous a prévenus
oh là là oh là là tu es attendu cerveau
toi mon gars oh la vache qu'est ce qui
s'est passé sa mère l'a appelé oui maman
j'arrive zhang c'était quoi ce n'est
qu'un couteau jeudi au cinéma c'est bon
ça c'est parfait c'est pas vrai
attendez on va essayer de continuer nous
ne coûtons couteau le deuxième couteau
d'un couteau et un cap avec derrière toi
quel est son but
a tué et mangé robert owen ou trop bien
le mur salut ok on s'en va alors on peut
aller on peut aller on peut aller
montpellier par la tension
ok la trompette jason qui s'excitent tue
ses déclarations
[ __ ] mais pourquoi je n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que j'ai on va
couper des dépenses tiac a annoncé un
chapeau de chantier tu me provoque tu
prends votre katana tu provoques d'un
bac époque oh là là avec le lag mon dieu
oh j'aurais pas dit que c'était comme ça
bon écoutez le sniper sais toujours pas
pour moi ouverte et dans une autre vidéo
si je suis un peu plus fort sniper en
tout cas l'on essaie de passer par là
non est un mec il m'a vu à françoise
dolto t.banon pause accroupi au faut
qu'on tourne debout
c'est génial quelle classe [ __ ] qu'est
ce que j'aime ou bien mais qu'ils
mangeaient le soldat appartenait lui il
mangeait du béton au but on va se faire
défoncer par la droite je le sens de
s'en aller en cours au courant qu
tu pourras jamais la classe mes potes
imposteur
espèce d'impasse tard c'est quoi ça
c'est la vidéo elle est vide on consomme
à elle tient ce soir la bataille
commence
alors oui c'est vrai que je suis assez
content là de faire cette vidéo dans ce
sens pour moi il ya le bac qui arrivent
et je vais devoir entamer des révisions
je travaillais un peu le soir à 20
heures à 18 heures à 22 heures bref
travailler tout simplement pour avoir ce
foutu bac parce que oui les diplômes
c'est important et nous devons
travailler voilà je vous ai tous faits
des primes est allé on serait plus en
danger tous parlent à poil de cul voilà
comment on fait chez nous et le diadème
il est 3e 3e 3e
août au maire d' homicide ou malraux que
mesut j'avais oublié que jamais le
tomahawk une somme a hélas si je suis un
mec ça serait le rêve eh bien non où ils
sont faits exploser labadie dont mme
essais nucléaires en approche sont fait
exploser la vache alors ils sont souvent
des piscines dans ses analyses sur la
gauche au nord sur la gauche qui en
avait un nom il y en a j'adore faire ça
ait du mois du mois euh tu m'as vu tu
m'avais coucou allez on s'en va
non quand même
assez énervant ça quand ça fait ça
[ __ ] la vache
j'avais le couteau cros maps ou là ils
passent
eux non monsieur
salut
c'est une blague mais avec mes amis les
gens aiment échoué avec une barre à égal
impossible comment veux tu faire quoi
que ce soit quand tu as une barre je ne
comprends pas on va essayer d'aller eux
au début d'explosion basse paris si tu
veux gagner de l'argent en mousse
[ __ ] qui fait de l'explosion qui veut
se faire péter les chronos je comprends
pas tu me vois avant que j'arrive ou
comment ça se passe tu es jeux superman
spiderman tué anticipations
maintenant
j'en avais la barrière contourner
terrain on
contourne non au coton demain fail c'est
affreux mais dis donc c'est qu'ils vont
gagner des millions c'est qu'ils vont
gagner ce genre de bien alors je ne sais
pas comment les points sont foutus
gb 4 alex j'y vais avec mon katana à
ogeu pris la grenade je t'emmerde
n'importe quoi on voit plus
grand bar vous ratez rien thomas cook au
merde allez on prend là pour faire le la
skil of the death
tintin
on passe au dessus de khat alex on court
au regard de radars vous avez vu on ne
trouve pas une guerre est là
warren a tous voila ce we find 11 août
alors il restait un bon bah tant pis et
en attendant vous pouvez aussi voir mon
troisième âge et c'est là
c'est affreux bontempi j'ai chopé ça
dans la nuit j'ai pas compris en tout
cas écoutez c'était la classe noces
j'espère que cette petite vidéo des tops
vous aura plu on se retrouve bientôt
pour un tomb raider sur tout le monde
pis
[Musique]